ciao ragazzi ciao ragazze a grande
richiesta ecco a voi il video sulle
tipologie di fidanzate qualche match
edoardo che era con me il video tipo
dato fidanzata quale delle tipologie che
abbiamo fatto ma un po 145 anche ok a
caldo ma sai che forse anche sono un po
11 e forse anche un po però aspetta
forse meglio piaciuto guardare forse mai
elis in time 123 fronte si necessario
amore dolorose e tra due mesi d'amore di
torino che ti sei riportando ma va detto
sono tutte top ma allora partito non ama
questo perché la vista che ancora il
tenente in materia di lidia in una d'ora
in avanti li guardi un po brahms non so
dolce sensuale e ammiccante dici amore
mi senti che fai
amore sei unica il mio amore mi ha
passato due rose per il momento entra
ispettori che non preparare bene cos'è
che hai il giorno 26 giu sito sola cosa
che tanto ci penso
in studio si è risolto visto che quella
ragazza che ha salutato il tunnel è
salvata soltanto da dicevo io ma qua
gatta ci cova chi cazzo verso il lavoro
che non solo non l'avrei sono stati
aperti sette persone saluti così va bene
no saltarle di lago ti ha fatto
stiamo litigando per una città a cui
stai guardando il cui fai schifo ma dove
stavo guardando la moto amore ma come ti
sei svestita
no non va bene collega questa capitali
anche far andare a safari park la
metterei cambiati completamente
allenamenti che il completo hugo boss
quello burgundi quella che dice lavandai
tocco di classe gli spring atti testa di
moro video regalato per il suo
compleanno
[Musica]
ti prego non ha ribattuto un chilo di
aglio segnali da 100 d'amore amore è
cambiato qualcosa che prolifera lo sento
cos'altro percepisco ios a insetti tutta
la vibrazione negativa che sia arrivato
a testare i disegni che ieri sera ha
risposto più di 37 dopo è di solito non
lo fai la prima volta sonate cenacolo
suo tempo votato come avvenne più dati
allora quasi dirà no no no no marchi
giuro che ti fa soltanto bene te lo
giuro
allora litro andiamo un po ti faccio
ultimo seggio non vibra te lo devo a
schiacciare ne vale la bellezza
l'atalanta è proprio lì che sta per
uscire perdente
bello bellissimo visto
testi che diamo a tema cinema dai
abbiamo il cinema amore io vado con la
pretesa c'è amore che non ci guarda cui
mentre il mio amore alle grazie via
lascia quindi era già sapete che volevo
ci vedi perché non mi conosci st 20
vederti ai miei chiedo perché sapevano
che mi piace solo a me piace la genitori
rilascio dei ragazzi truccate insomma
messa a bada tutti i tutorial e muove
borsa è vero però solo per pino palazzo
e poi tutti i tatuaggi per sempre le
grilli e ad hoc figli da vero questo che
devo fare
lo fa come tu dici ma diciamo che non
trascuri io ma se mi piace una bella
porta che dice di più abbiamo subito il
chirurgo ma molto diciamo vi faccio
vedere solo per te amore
[Musica]
ma lei si addosso però cavolo dai seno
atroce ancora quanti bei lo sapevi fanno
schifo per i no figurati ragazzo infatti
la ceretta coca cola mi sdraio e rotti i
[ __ ] massa ciao amore mi quadra come
la voglio vedere quanti più posti dove i
dati in questo nome
se però passa da hai visto per caso mia
felpa verde pantalone nero e scarpe con
perdite mancare anche gli occhiali da
sole neri e sposati tu te li ho buttati
d'amore che difese c dove gli amici peso
presa male che siamo visti neanche
deputato tutto fosse da rinchiudere sei
tu che mi hai chiamato alla pasta di
facebook su due giochi che le scope
entrare e ci credo cioè tutti quelli ti
vedi mettevano la aic insomma mi dava
fastidio sa come sono fatta
allora adesso che non c'è più nessun
profilo su facebook su instagram nei
metalli fioravante nessuno devo mettere
la scusa visto più tranquilla molto bene
noi siamo curiosissimi sapere cuore
tipologia il fidanzato e siete voi
quindi mi raccomando commentate qui
sotto se vi è piaciuto il video
iscrivetevi come sempre al canale e
seguitemi sui vari social facebook
instagram stage up e musicali io vi
saluto e io vedo recuperare le sedi nel
cassonetto o adoro ciao
[Musica]